muy bien problema número 10 problema
número 10 y tiene que ver con ecuaciones
de valor absoluto de lujo dice el valor
absoluto de 10 menos camps esto es igual
a 3 y por otra parte déjame cambiar de
color
tengo que el valor absoluto de k menos 5
esto es igual a 8 perfecto am y lo que
me preguntan es cuál es el valor de
campo que cumple ambas ecuaciones
simultáneamente estoy buscando un valor
para camps que cumpla estas dos
ecuaciones bueno de la primera actuación
tengo que el valor absoluto de 10 - k
esto es igual a 3 y bueno recordando las
propiedades de las ecuaciones con valor
absoluto
esto significa que 10 - k es igual a 3 o
en su dado caso o en su dado caso
- cam esto es igual a menos 3 tengo
estas dos posibles expresiones y en la
primera tendría que camps es igual a 7
10 menos 7 es igual a 3 mientras que la
segunda que valdría 13 porque 10 menos
13 es igual a menos 3 entonces ya tengo
dos posibles valores para camps los dos
posibles son soluciones de la primera
actuación como el absoluto pero ahora me
tengo que fijar en la segunda ecuación
con valor absoluto que dice el valor
absoluto de cada menos 5 esto es igual a
8 y de aquí tengo que okah menos 5 esto
es igual a 8 o en su dado caso
camino cinco esto es igual a menos otro
muy bien y de la primera que valdría 13
13 58 esto está fácil de la segunda
valdría pasos te parezca menos 3 menos
35 es menos 8 ahora estas dos casas son
las soluciones de esta ecuación de color
azul que tiene el valor absoluto
mientras que estas dos cajas de
amarillos son las soluciones de esta
ecuación de amarillo con valor absoluto
lo que me preguntan es cuál es el valor
de camps que satisface ambas ecuaciones
simultáneamente y te das cuenta acá
igual a 7 satisface esta pero no
satisface está por lo tanto éste no es
acá igual a menos 3 satisface esta pero
no satisface está por lo tanto ésta no
es igual a 13 satisface ambas está
y esto por lo tanto ese es justo el
resultado acá igual a 13 satisface ambas
ecuaciones con valor absoluto entonces
ya está esto estaba muy fácil así que
vamos a hacer el siguiente problema
déjame borrar el pizarrón y vamos a
hacer el problema número 11 que por
cierto está lleno de líneas así que
déjame hacerlas por aquí tengo una línea
parecida a ésta tengo a una línea
perpendicular por aquí me dicen de hecho
que es perpendicular y tengo otra recta
que pasa justo por este punto y sigue y
sigue y sigue es una recta como esta y
después tengo otra recta rara que parte
de aquí y se va por acá perfecto a que
otras cosas me dan bueno me dicen que
este ángulo de 90 grados vamos a cambiar
colores este ángulos un ángulo recto muy
bien por otra parte me dicen
que este ángulo mide 65 grados 65 grados
que este de aquí y de 20 grados 20
grados y por último que este de aquí me
dé x lo voy a poner con otro color
porque tras este vamos yo lo que quiero
saber es el valor de x y si tú recuerdas
este es el famoso juego de dos ángulos
hay que cazar ángulos hasta obtener el
valor de x y para esto hay que pensar un
poco en todos los ángulos que se forman
por ejemplo este con este estos 2 éste y
éste son ángulos complementarios es
decir la suma de ambos me dan 90 grados
este más este media 90 grados porque ya
tengo 90 grados ya 65 grados cuánto le
falta para hacer 90 grados
le faltan 25 grados 25 grados
exactamente a ver 5 y 5 son 10 y
llevamos 16 y unas 12 son 10 16 y unas
son siete y dos son nueve perfectos 90
grados
y si yo quiero sacar a x fíjate bien
fíjate en esta recta que tengo aquí esta
de aquí me está delimitando a equis
déjame ponerla con otro color así esta
recta me está delimitando a x porque
porque yo tengo aquí a x atrapada y este
ángulo en general debe de sumar 180
grados dicho de otra manera 20 más x más
25 deben de sumar 180 grados porque son
ángulos suplementarios y cuánto me
faltan para llegar a los 180 grados a
ver pongámoslo aquí 20 grados más x
grados más 25 grados esto me tiene que
sumar 180 grados porque estamos de este
lado de esta recta y si yo sumo aquí me
queda que x grados más 45 grados esto es
igual a 180 y ya está
x es igual a 180 menos 45 es decir 135
grados y esa es mi respuesta así que
creo que me merezco un poco de pavo del
recalentado
gracias después de resolver estos
problemas déjenme borrar esta pantalla y
vamos a hacer el siguiente problema el
problema número 12 12 que dice lo
siguiente ojo bueno y el último problema
estaba marcado de manera incorrecta por
mi sobrina así que me tomé un poco de
tiempo para verificarlo en verdad juro
que no fui yo quien marcó la respuesta
de manera incorrecta
pero era un problema número 12 dice la
mediana de un conjunto de nueve enteros
consecutivos
tengo un conjunto de nueve entre los
consecutivos aquí tengo
dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete ocho
nueve y dice que la mediana de este
conjunto de nueve enteros consecutivos
es 42 cuál es el mayor de estos enteros
muy interesante si es la mediana es el
valor que está justo en medio y cuál de
estos valores es el que está justo en
medio bueno pues aquí tengo 1234 aquí
tengo 1234 este es el que está justo en
medio por lo tanto este debe de ser mi
mediana y mediana que por cierto yo sé
que vale 42 42 esta es mi mediana si
estas mediana es decir el que está justo
en medio cuanto 6 después de la mediana
pues hay 12 34 hay 4 y antes de esta
mediana hay 4 por que en total suman 94
más cuatro más este son nueve enteros
hoy además me dicen que son consecutivos
ya está siendo el medio es 42 y son
consecutivos entonces el que sigue sería
43 el que sigue sería 44 el que sigue
sería 45 y por último sería 46 el más
grande de todos ellos es 40
6 que es la respuesta de este problema
número 12 46 43 44 45 46 perfecto estos
son de los problemas que nos ahorran un
poco de tiempo así que no hay más que
decir de este problema lo voy a borrar y
vamos a hacer el siguiente problema el
problema número 13 lo voy a hacer de
color rojo el problema número 13 y me
dice lo siguiente si fx efe de x está
definida de la siguiente manera
fx es igual a x + 1
muy bien y además sabemos que efe que
dos veces fdp fdp dos veces fdp esto es
igual a 20 entonces lo que me preguntan
es cuánto vale
efe de 3 p efe de 3 p esto es lo que yo
quiero saber
ok y como lo supuesto bueno pues es
simple y sencillamente aplicar la
definición de una función yo se que fx
es x + 1 y que dos veces fp es igual a
20 dicho de otra manera si sustituyó
aquí ap me va a quedar que dos veces fdp
pero fdp es uno más uno lo único que
estoy haciendo sustituyendo a x por p
entonces me queda dos veces p más uno
esto es igual a 20 y de aquí puedo
obtener el valor de esta es una cuestión
muy sencilla si distribuyó el 2 me va a
quedar a 2 p más 2 esto es igual a 20 o
dicho de otra manera 2 p esto es igual a
18 y si divido todo entre 2 me queda que
p es igual a 9 perfecto me vale 9 y
entonces quien es f de 3p pues efe de
3pm es lo mismo
de tres por nueve de tres por nueve y
esto es lo mismo que f de 27 y f de 27
como está definida la función es lo
mismo que 27 más 1 recuerda que la
función está definida así como x + 1 y
27 más uno es 28 28 es la respuesta de
este problema
efe 3 pep es decir efe de 27 y 28 y ya
está otro problema más que estaba
bastante sencillo así que vamos a
resolver el siguiente problema a mí me
gustan nuestros problemas problema
número 14 14 y dice lo siguiente y bueno
parece ser que tengo una figura bastante
entretenida pero hay que tener mucho
cuidado por lo tanto voy a dibujarla muy
grande tengo algo así y después tengo
una recta que va por acá perfecto y
después tengo una recta que es
perpendicular a ésta
a algo más o menos como por aquí
perfecto después tengo otra que también
aquí es perpendicular así que voy a
intentar dibujarla a esta también es
perpendicular entonces es algo así
después tengo una línea que une estas
dos es algo aquí y tengo un montón de
letras así que déjame ponerte todas
estas letras tengo aquí j j acá
j k l j k l m j k l m n perfecto y
después también me dan algunos datos me
dicen que este ángulo es de 90 grados
bueno esto ya lo sabemos este ángulo
también las de 90 grados este de aquí
también es de 90 grados y además me
dicen que este ángulo de aquí vale 125
grados y por cierto yo lo que quiero
saber es cuánto vale x y x es este
ángulo que tengo aquí este de aquí es x
grados muy bien y por último me dicen
que las longitudes de l n la longitud de
l en esta longitud y la longitud de l m
en esta longitud son iguales son la
misma es decir que esta longitud y esta
longitud son iguales y me preguntan
cuánto vale x muy bien pues esto me
recuerda bastante al fuego de los
ángulos lo que vamos a hacer es cazar la
mayor cantidad de ángulos posibles
lo primero que quiero que veas es que
este triángulo de aquí es un triángulo
isósceles y si es un triángulo isósceles
este lado y este lado miden lo mismo y
por lo tanto este ángulo y este ángulo
miden lo mismo entonces creo que yo
puedo saber este ángulo de una manera
muy fácil porque 125 grados más este
ángulo tienen que sumar 180 son ángulos
suplementarios entonces cuánto le falta
a 125 para llegar a 180
me quedaría 50 55 grados este ángulo
mide 55 grados bueno al menos ya sé un
ángulo más pero si este vale 55 grados
que crees esto también vale 55 grados
eso lo podemos saber de una manera muy
sencilla porque es triángulo equilátero
y bueno este vale 55 grados
esteban 55 grados creo que ya podemos
saber cuánto vale este es lo que nos
hace falta para sumar 180 55 55 más éste
deben de sumar 180
que la suma de todos los ángulos de un
triángulo debe de ser 180 grados
por lo tanto 55 más 55 y 110 110 para
180 este vale 70 grados 70 grados vamos
bien hasta aquí no hay ningún problema y
después creo que ya podemos saber este
de aquí este de aquí
fíjate bien este vale 90 este debe de
valer 90 también y por lo tanto 70 más
este ángulo que me faltan son ángulos
complementarios
es decir que 70 más este suman 90 o
dicho de otra manera cuánto le falta 70
para llegar a 90 bueno pues nos faltan
20 grados por lo tanto este de aquí vale
20 grados éste equivale 20 grados y
jajaja ya podemos encontrar a x por qué
darte cuenta de lo siguiente estamos en
un triángulo en qué triángulo déjame ver
si te lo puedo dibujar aquí fíjate en
este triángulo este triángulo nos va a
dar la solución
este este este triángulo nosotros
sabemos que este ángulo de 90 grados
este ángulo mide 20 grados y este mide
lo que queremos
x grados pero la suma de todos los
ángulos de un triángulo es 180 grados es
decir que 90 grados
x grados
a 20 grados esto tiene que ser igual a
180 grados todo esto porque estamos en
este triángulo este es el triángulo
importante y ahora si 90 + 20 es lo
mismo que 110 110 grados más x grados
esto es igual a 180 grados y ahora si yo
restó 110 de ambos lados de esta
ecuación me va a quedar que x grados es
igual a 70 grados de lujo x vale 70 y
esta es la respuesta de este problema
pero como ya estoy corriendo en tiempo
por aquí te voy a dejar así que nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo